the absolute conviction and sincerity of
these words
would frankly lead anybody to have no
doubt about whether these commitments
are going to be
kept on the private sector
commitments pledges these are very
significant
and these companies biome fights and
modern
and johnson johnson are certainly have
committed their whole reputation to this
uh it's a it's a very very important
move that really will change the
landscape because
if they keep on having these donations
in the on this rhythm
many of the controversial questions on
how we sure
production of vaccines in ldcs how
we make sure that
patents are sort of used also to
liberalize the use of vaccines
well they still very important but they
somehow are less
important so i have no no doubt
however your question was also in the
minds of many who spoke
who kind of vented the hypothesis
that we we might need a treaty
so a form more binding than this
declaration but i think a lot of work
has to be done on that
the future is still open please yes
thank you um
indeed let's let's put it in uh two
parts
um the answer the first one are indeed
the
pledges or the commitments that are have
been given today
and of course in preparation of such a
g20
summit we work hard with different
countries
or with our european industrial partners
to get these commitments so they are
well thought through
and they were public so publicly said
biontech
pfizer that they will they committed to
deliver
1 billion doses this year
at non-profit for low-income countries
and lower costs for middle-income
countries i think this is a very clear
public statement the same goes for 200
million
this year from johnson and johnson and
100
million this year from moderna
so the the companies have very well
thought about it
and can be held accountable because
they know that they have said that
publicly same goes
for team europe pledging 100 million
dollars is till the end of the year
to be donated many of them through
kovacs not all of them but many of them
through cobax so here too
we feel responsible and accountable and
then the second part
is the rome declaration i think it
is groundbreaking and really historical
because
you have for the very first time the g20
that is the united states and china the
european union
and russia india and latin america
south africa and many others all of them
committing to basic principles
at the beginning the big principle of
multilateralism that goes like a
golden threat through the declaration
what is so important in there important
is that this is a very
clear no to health nationalism
and it is even reinforced if you look in
the declaration
um at a certain point you found the
principle
that supply chains have to be
open so clear no to export bans
a clear no to bottlenecks and all the
countries i was mentioning the g20
have agreed on that um or
another topic that is in the rome
declaration
is the commitment to the one health
principle
so for the very first time there is the
admittance that climate change
loss of biodiversity and human activity
expanding into wildlife is one
of the breeding grounds or the forces
that brings forward
those pandemics and
these are principles where we from now
on can build on so we can refer to these
principles
we can call for deliveries on these
principles
and therefore i think this is a very
important and groundbreaking day today
yeah for just just to follow on on your
point how we make sure that these
these commitments are going to be held
in the future
clearly key will be the involvement of
multilateral organizations
like the wto the wto is the forum
where many of these issues are going to
be discussed the
removal of export bans the intellectual
property rights
the ensuring the flow the continuous
flow
of the supply chains of these medicines
which is quite which are quite complex
so the we have discovered that the
complete openness of boundaries is
essential
to provide to produce vaccines to
produce them
in as you can see from the pledges in
huge quantities
and to make sure they're going to be
distributed to everybody
so wto who the world health
organization as well there was a
pledging or a manifested will to finance
it
to make it more effective so there are
many interesting things but certainly
the
first of all the assurance that these
commitments are going to be held is in
the strength of their words in the
sincerity of their words the second
it's going to be in the hands of these
organizations
thank you we have a second question from
euro news george orlandy
the eu has recently reached a a deal on
pogba 19 certificates to open up
tourism across the continent although it
looks like might take a while because
before
this can come into effect now with the
summer season that is about to begin i'd
like to ask
prime minister mario draghi how is italy
planning
to deal with such a delay what's the
impact in italy
and i'd like to put a similar question
to president van der lyon
if she thinks it's a bit too late and
what's your take on this thank you
well perhaps here um if you allow please
don't
you ask first so indeed our goal is to
be ready
in june uh this is for it's important we
have good news
that yesterday the political agreement
is
uh what has been achieved between the
european parliament and the council a
precondition
to move forward of course there is hard
work to do on the technical side
but we are right now in may in the
process of doing
uh test runs with the different member
states
and i must say that member states have
to do their homework on the technical
side what data are concerned
so most of them are ready not all of
them
are in time but most of them italy is
excellent in time
so that is good and
we are counting on starting in july june
excuse me not in july but in june
with the eu certificate and it is a
european contribution
also to boost tourism again
we um by the end of april
i can't remember the exact date but the
government's taken some important
decisions about reopening the economy
and one of these decisions taken either
there or 10 days later
was to eliminate the quarantine
for citizens coming from the schengen
area from the uk
from the emirates from the united states
the second thing we did specific was to
strengthen the
so-called coffee tested flights
and we again we have expanded that in
fact to other cities
in in italy um so we want the tourists
back
we want them soon italy is open to the
tourists so
all the world and that's the main
message
i want to say there is going to be a
green pass european level italy will
have its own green pass
before and we are coordinating with the
commission
in order to have exactly the same but we
in the meantime we will have our
national green pass
and that will also be helpful but the
key point is that
we see that the general situation of the
pandemia
is improving and that gives a lot of
confidence
and a lot of confidence and trust in the
future
and that's the best in a sense the best
way
to welcome tourists from all the world
thank you and now chico heartland
washington post
thank you very much um i would welcome
either of you to answer this
it's it's up to you but you know
certainly there was
near unanimity today um among all the
leaders that the current
inequities are unacceptable
or problematic even even immoral
but you didn't hear anybody apologizing
for
their own decisions and indeed they come
from pretty understandable political
imperatives uh to take care of your own
citizens
and it maybe even has an element of
human nature
so do you see anything in
what unfolded today that would prevent
that pattern from playing out again
you know even with with booster shots
and with all the next rounds of
of demands that will take place even
here across europe
um does that pattern change and should
it change
thank you please also use that yes it
has to change and it is changing
so if i may
refer to what is needed to ensure
equitable access
what we've seen is first of all of
course boost production
what we did intensively and as europeans
we went through the experience that it
is doable
to serve your own population but also
export we have over
uh the last four five months now
have on had on average fifty percent of
the european production
exported up to today fifty percent have
been exported
we have delivered to the european people
around 230 or 240
million doses and the same amount has
been
exported to 90 countries um
covax included that is the point number
one and this
is also of course in the rom declaration
that bottlenecks
should be avoided and that
we need open supply chains very
important
but the point number one is and this is
a learning process also
we saw that also today that this will
not be enough
and therefore that we have to step up to
increase manufacturing capacities
in other regions of the world that are
not typically producing vaccines
this is one of the initiatives
our learning process here of team europe
to
systematically build up a vaccination or
manufacturing
capacity in different regions
in africa so to build regional hubs
1 billion will be invested it's together
with the member states
and financial institutions and of course
our african partners
what is the system it's building
infrastructure
it is making sure that the industrial
partners the pharmaceutical companies
share knowledge and license and are
involved in this building of capacities
skilling people from university to dual
vocational training this is one of the
bottlenecks
and of course of course making sure that
the supply chains are there
there are projects that have already
started
like in south africa or senegal one
that's also interesting
and i want to be very clear it's also
about
bringing mrna technologies to africa
so this is also included we have our as
i said industrial partners
i think this is the most important um
stepping stone for the medium and long
term
at the moment being in the short term
donations
export sharing of vaccines but
this mechanism is over time not
sustainable over time
you need more production or
manufacturing facilities
to be built up in these different
regions
thank you also may i add one point about
first i would start where ursula also
started if there is one part of the
world
that behaved just a little better than
average
that was europe even while we were
starving for vaccines we have thousands
of people dying every day
we kept on exporting exactly as much as
it was available
for ourselves
exporting also furthermore to countries
that were blocking their exports
so that is the reality of our experience
with with this there were people who
used to say
uh not in rome in brussels we are dying
of experts
so that was the perception at some point
here now not long ago a month and a half
ago
the other thing basili the message is
we have understood we all made mistakes
now it's time to repair one of the one
of the things that people we're not
thinking about that now because we talk
about vaccines
but there is another potential
catastrophe here for poor countries
namely a debt a sovereign debt
catastrophe
that's looming because these countries
have been hit
by the crisis the economic crisis
because of the pandemia and also because
of their weak conditions before the
pandemia
so now what the international community
and
also the imf the world bank are trying
to do now is to set up a package
which would somehow make the debt
servicing conditions better namely that
will have to be restructured no
questions about that
and there will have to be an extra
distribution of special drawing rights
for them
and next next and here is the in a sense
it drives us back to the point of
sharing
the other point important point is
whether we can share
the special drawing rights of countries
that don't don't need them
with those who need them which is
a very big amount thank you
donna now the floor is yours thank you
very much
paula so we will take a couple of
questions from brussels
i see several hands raised where are you
and uh please let's give the floor first
to norwich
from honda's blood moritz go ahead
thank you so much for taking my question
um a question for
both uh president folderline and
prime minister draghi you already
mentioned
open supply chains more than once
that you have this commitment now in the
g20
declaration um have the uk
and the us in particular permitted to
any concrete steps
to make good on this commitment and to
open up their supply chains
what do you expect them to do and as a
follow-up
how much of a problem for
european manufacturers are those
restrictions that the u.s
has imposed still at this point
resource thank you yes so um it's very
clear
the the countries you mentioned have uh
as all g20 endorsed
and assigned the wrong declaration
and you find it detailed out in the
wrong declaration
what the supply chains are concerned if
i look into my paper so i can cite it to
you
but indeed it's a principle four the g20
commits two
eyesight open resilient diversified
secured
efficient and reliable global supply
chains
so um this is agreed
um by all g20 and i think
that is a big step forward
now we have indeed
learned also our lessons what the
interruption of supply chains is
concerned
as you know for example to produce mrna
vaccines i have learned that 280
components are necessary
so it is a very complex procedure
our experience is wherever there is a
blockage
it hampers the whole process not only in
the receiving country but there are side
effects
into other countries too which is then
like a bouncing back effect to the
country
that started with blocking for example
the flow of raw material
or components so it is not it's in no
one's
interest it is in our common interest to
keep the supply chains up
and in that we are in very good uh talks
now
with the uk and with the united states
so there is no blockage of raw material
or components anymore
i i just want to make another point on
this
it's uh i wouldn't say easy
but it's um in a sense more
i should say more uh
well easy it's easier to do these
pledges now
and i'm pretty sure the u.s will ban
their
exports barriers we'll take them off
we'll leave them off
because there's plenty of access right
now
most of the population has been
vaccinated both in us and in europe
and in uk so now there is availability
for
the rest of the world and it's going to
go like this
until the next pandibia
until the next surprise so
we should use this time and this is also
in the declaration today
to make sure that somehow countries
bind themselves not only on this
occasion but also in the future
and that's why multilateral
organizations which are institutions
with the treaty
can be extremely helpful in the coming
months in order to make sure that we
don't repeat
what's happened this time with poor
countries
thank you thank you president and prime
minister we take a
second question from brussels let me see
the hands raised
yes the next one will be frederick boa
from liquor federick go ahead
i thank you thank you very much for for
the floor
and a first one would be
uh the the proposal of the imf uh
they they said that um a 50
billion plan would be necessary to fight
the pandemic
how do you see it is the european union
ready to to do even more than what
has already been announced
and a second question if i may for
mrs pandelarian the digital
certificate as far as i understand the
commission is working with the world
health
organization to ensure that this
certificate can be recognized
elsewhere in the world as well are you
confident it will be the case in uh
in the near future thank you very much
i think i leave the financial question
to you
the certificate
indeed yes who
approved vaccines are recognized and
i'm not the the perfect ex
the perfect situation to explain all the
technicalities
but the system the european gateway
system we
establish for our member states has the
ability
that third countries plug in so that
it's interoperable
with other countries third countries
outside of the european union
so the perspective is that over time
we we can not only apply the
european uh certificate for the member
states but
also for third countries that plug in
with their data
thank you the um
we actually don't know whether 50
billions are
the amounts that are needed but even if
so
there is a consistent significant
package that
i hinted at before which starts with the
distribution of special drawing rights
then the redistribution of special
drawing rights for the countries that
have them don't use them can they lend
it to
the poor countries then we have a
mechanism called
ida international development aid
replenishment
and that this year all countries have
committed to
to do bigger commitments in that pool
and then we have what i mentioned before
the debt restructuring
serious quite significant and then you
have
national and international and
multilateral contributions
like the ones if you think today a small
country
like italy has pledged 300 million
to the kovacs and also has pledged 15
million
vaccines in the donation pool
and certainly it's not the biggest
pledge
and then you have the private sector
that also is
is working actively and frankly it's not
the last
or the least important thing so all this
will help not only in the vaccine
campaign during the vaccine campaign but
also in laying out the infrastructure
that will help poor countries to react
better to the next pandemia
an infrastructure that starts as as
president
as usual just said with the
identification of production sites in
africa for example
that's quite important the transfer of
technology of know-how
by the private sector and then the
production
but also an infrastructure in health
infrastructure and also on this there is
ample agreement in poor countries that
needs to be held to build
so today i frankly have no
no doubt that what's needed will be
found
valentina antonello
um
is
[Music]
so i'm talking about the compulsory
licensing
declaration yes please i'm happy to oh
you have the translation yeah but it was
an excellent translation
so um of course the voluntary licensing
is the best way to ensure that
necessary transfer of technology and
know-how
will go together with ip rights having
said that
i think it is very interesting and a
real step forward
that today the global community that is
the g20
acknowledged the intellectual property
is an
instrument to boost manufacturing
capacity
and what you find in the rom declaration
is that the g20 committed to working
on this subject thoroughly within the
existing
trips agreement and the so-called doha
declaration
so what is it all about in the trips
agreement
is already and in the doha declaration
is already today foreseen
a compulsory licensing as a
perfectly legitimate tool in
extraordinary situation and pandemic of
course is an
extraordinary situation so it's already
foreseen the compulsory licensing is
already foreseen
in the trips agreement with the doha
declaration this has been reconfirmed by
g20 today
this is also important if you look at
the parties that are
convened in g20 now
what the prime minister is referring to
is that i've been listening very
carefully
to the developing countries we had on
monday or tuesday in paris
also with african leaders a summit on
this topic
and they are complaining that it is
difficult for them to use these
flexibilities
within trips within the doha declaration
and therefore we think we have to act to
provide
the security and the certainty that
developing countries can use
the flexibilities in the trips agreement
and therefore the european union will
come forward
with a proposal in wto
in early june to offer a third way
a third way that is also in support of
the ideas the director general of wto dr
ngozi
has so our proposal
we have been discussing it yesterday in
the trade council
in the european union roughly will
will have three components the first one
we've been discussing already
that is trade facilitation and
disciplines
on export restrictions so to make that
sure also in wto
support for expansion of production
we've been talking about that
and indeed on ip clarifying and
simplifying the use of
compulsory licenses in crisis times like
a pandemic
if necessary what do i want to say by
that first of all it's important that
g20 has
convened behind this no hard declaration
and the trips agreement that we work
within it with the flexibilities second
your question how can you ensure that
it's really
going forward we now take the initiative
and bring the european proposal
to the wto table where then the
ambassadors in wto will discuss
and deal with it so we move the whole
topic forward
and i think this is one of the good
outcomes of today
thank you ursula
thank you thank you we closed this press
conference
thank you president thank you prime
minister thank you everybody
[Music]
okay